[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
everything has an appointed season and
there's a time for every matter under
heaven a time to give birth a time to
die a time to plant and a time to
harvest what is planted a time to weep
and a time to laugh colleagues friends
family of the extraordinary visionary
galvanizing and remarkable Vincent J
Scully jr. welcome over the centuries
Yale has been lucky lucky to have its
rightful share of charismatic scholars
and teachers people who've moved
knowledge forward changed minds and
lives with their powerful teaching tales
of Benjamin Silliman holding his
chemistry classroom spellbound or of
John Pitkin Norton inspiring students
and the general public about the
practical value of applying scientific
methods to agriculture abound in Yale
history but I'm quite confident
confident that even among these there is
no single person in all of our over 317
years who did this as well or for as
long a time period as Vincent Scully and
so Vince may be unique in the annals of
Yale
I'm not going to try to say much about
Vince now because many others here will
do that today instead I'm simply going
to say that the single word that is
appropriate for what he gave to Yale is
our gratitude we are grateful for Vince
once in a long while someone like
vince comes along and we are fortunate
when that miracle the miracle of Scully
happens to us happens to us here at Yale
this afternoon we'll begin with a short
video clip of Vince himself followed by
speakers other video clips and some
music that will bring him back to us and
allow us surrounded by the community of
so many who loved him to pay tribute to
him one more time thank you for being
here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that kind of synthesis of those things
that are in Corbusier and Otto dominated
all the time by this beautifully humane
sense of the receiving of the light of
every day now this house has had a
significant history now it's true that
when it's caught published it he praised
it for a very modern quality he said it
has almost no detail very spare and
sparse no decoration because he was
still seeing it as a modernist now this
is the building in his book that caught
my eye precisely for the same reason I
was prepared to see basically still in a
modernist way George Hamilton Yale who
was my adviser but be in touch for the
Henry Russell Hitchcock was really the
Dean of architectural historians at that
time and he was a very generous adviser
for me in my dissertation which was on
American 19th century architecture and
then I published a book about that the
shingle style in post-world War two u.s.
you'd see all these quotes shingle style
buildings but you never knew that they
were shingle style or even architecture
they were not in any books they were not
talked about in any way and
systematically and suddenly you have
Scully present them if the complex
arguments that he developed for them
both spatially tectonic Lee culturally
linked to the literature the politics of
the day it was amazing suddenly what
were just buildings became architecture
this is the General Motors Hamas of 1939
it shows you how nice it would be the
buildings on both sides you know you
notice are conforming to the spin of the
road the buildings are formed by that
movement of those automobiles the
automobile is everything doesn't matter
what you knock down if you get from one
place to another in two minutes faster
by knocking down a whole street that's
100 years old you've got to do it
because that's reasonable to get that
faster
[Music]
I paid no attention when Phillip Johnson
and John Lindsay bigoted should try to
save Pennsylvania station in 1963
like most modernists at that time I just
didn't think it really saving anything
here you had to be new that's ridiculous
when redevelopment however developed in
New Haven I began to see you couldn't
just stay in your ivory tower anymore no
I couldn't just be interested in the
Greek temples that to come back to my
hometown
[Music]
apparently arrow came out here and flew
balloons at various Heights they let
some go up and he pulls him down
to try to get the heights of the towers
so the height of every tower was arrived
at empirically and purely visually than
the number of floors of rooms they have
are determined by the visual character
of its height then when Khan came along
and he was here before you were at Yale
and you never studied with him no but I
did my architecture on the top floor at
least the part it was good up there was
a great stretch is fantastic and this is
the first building built when he's in
this early 50s and which he tries to
start again if you compare with that one
it too is very reductive it's so little
here compared with what's there but
there is a kind of splint
there's a kind of sense of a beginning
he's really starting here to try to
understand what a classical building in
a town is this is the first barn Billy
ale and to my mind the most moving
with the possible exception of the
British dart Center there are very few
times in the entire history of
architecture where an historian delves
into an area of architectural history
studies it interprets it puts it before
the audience including young architects
this was one of the rare times when an
architectural story and a profound
effect on architecture
[Music]
it is not quite true that architecture
was Vincent Scully's subject he taught
about it and wrote about it for more
than six decades and it is not possible
to imagine greater passion being brought
to it but his true life's work was
always something more something for
which the buildings in the cities that
are nominally his subject were but a
vehicle and that is the whole idea of
human community and culture if his work
contains any overriding message it is
that architecture is part of that larger
culture and that its meaning comes from
its connectedness to that larger culture
by now it's almost a commonplace to
observe that to honor Vince is almost
like honoring architecture itself which
indeed it is for he and architectures
noblest aims are virtually synonymous
but I want to say also that when we
think of Vince we think of something
else as much as architecture and that is
the idea of the world and the newly holy
connection that Vince forged between
architecture and language the search to
find meaning in this mysterious profound
and glorious relationship that there can
be between architecture and words for
what Vince did for his entire life was
to use words spoken words and written
words both in all their grave and
majestic power and beauty as a way of
helping us understand all that
architecture is and can be and can mean
I first encountered him when I was 16
years old an eager high school junior
making an exploratory visit to Yale a
friend had said that since I was
interested in architecture I should try
to look in at one of those lectures by
this architecture professor of
architectural history professor who well
he didn't know quite how to character
arise him but my friend said I would not
be disappointed I was not disappointed
for four years I sat in the Law School
Auditorium alas Yale would only give me
credit for one of those years but
nevertheless I kept coming back sitting
in those creaking seats watching and
listening wallowing and words and
rhythms that I loved hearing repeated
again and again his lectures were not
unlike a favorite piece of music and
when you were 20 years old you believed
that any piece of music worth hearing
cannot be heard too many times of course
hearing scholar year after year wasn't
really hearing the same thing because
the lectures were never exactly the same
part of what always made Vince so
special was that every lecture was
different and reflected his thinking at
exactly the moment he delivered it from
those years of sitting in the auditorium
that I learned from Vince not only about
Frank Lloyd Wright not only about Louie
Kahn not only about Robert venturi but
about several things that are much more
important than any architect Vince
taught us all that serious intellectual
inquiry need not be inconsistent with
passion and that empathy is a true and
legitimate part of analysis
he showed us that for all the joy there
is in knowledge for its own sake that
putting knowledge to active use for
social good is an even higher calling
and most important of all that the
making of architecture cannot be
separated from the making of community
indeed that the very purpose of
architecture is to make our common
ground our commonality via visible and
thereby to shape a civilization over
time Vince started his career as an
unabashedly braider of the most heroic
ambitions of modernism which he came
gradually to question one of his
greatest gifts as a teacher was his
ability to admit to both his students
and his readers
that he might have been wrong about
something that he had changed his mind
ultimately he would come to think of
urbanism as equally important to foreign
making and to cherish older building so
much that he became an ardent
preservationist he expressed regret as
we just saw in that clip for failing to
speak out against the demolition of
McInnes Pennsylvania Station saying in
what became one of his most famous lines
one entered the city like a god
now you scuttle in underground like a
rat not the least of the pleasures of
going first today is that I can use that
line without worrying if somebody else
will use it first in 1969 Vince wrote in
a much less quoted passage that art
history had to be conservative
experimental and ethical it was a
remarkable trio of words one that in
itself shows Vince's exquisite
sensitivity to language conservative
because he knew that our history had to
respect the past since learning from the
great work of history is central to its
purpose experimental because at the same
time Vince wanted to make the point that
the real value of understanding the
architecture of the past must be to
inspire the highest creativity in the
present and ethical because he believed
that the noblest mission of
architectural history at least as he
practiced it was to encourage the
building of community and the betterment
of civilization that is Vince's true
legacy his belief that words can change
the world
no Yale president could fail to
appreciate Vince's brilliance
originality and passion and the profound
life enriching impact he had on our
students that said Vince did not always
make life easy for a Yale president his
respect for the perfection of New
Haven's plan borrowed by John Davenport
from Ezekiel's vision of God's city and
his passion for the beauty and
authenticity of its buildings and parks
impelled him to hold Yale's buildings
and their placement to an exceedingly
high standard here's what he wrote at
the conclusion of the book that we
commissioned for Yale's tur Centennial
University buildings should be among the
city's most enduring it is after all
something like immortality that they
deal in offering an escape from the
restrictions to life that ignorant
imposes and a promise to lives unborn
this should be especially true of Yale
in New Haven God's City under the
mountain Haven of Exile heaven on earth
for all mankind to see Wow
this is a grand and inspiring aspiration
and in truth we work very hard to be
good stewards of the University and New
Haven but not every Yale project
proposed or executed met Vince's test
and when we failed to me to standard he
let us know a forceful argument and
characteristic passion it's appreciated
president Griswolds taste for modernist
buildings he celebrated Kahn's art
gallery
Rudolph's art in architecture building
Saren and this Engels rink and Johnson's
Science Hill suite but here is his
assessment of the by Nikki library
situated I use his words situated on an
empty plaza that was sterilized for it
by its architect as perfect as a table
radio and conveying no more sense of
architectural scale little wonder that
Vince went on to torment Kingman
Brewster by encouraging Claes Oldenburg
to deposit his lipstick ascending on
this very sterile Plaza Brewster are in
Vince's high marks for Cohn Center for
British art but Brewers Becton Center
was a double loser a truly terrible
building built on the site of two
buildings that Brent Vince believed
should never have been torn down
consider these words of withering scorn
like the by Nikki the Becton Center was
essentially a late modern abstraction a
chilling demonstration of that design in
folded paper at which the Harvard
Bauhaus excelled
the Pilates are flatly frontal while
that densely crinkled elements of the
buildings white facade of a blinding
white facade seemed to be derived from
the grave slabs of the growth Street
Cemetery across the way the rear wall
rises up as a blank lead geometric
abstraction especially obtrusive and
hard to bear from one sickbed at the
Yale Health Services Center across you
get it I had my own taste of vince's
wrath early in my presidency when we
demolished maple cottage and when we
made alterations that he regarded as
intolerable to the balcony of the
Berkeley College dining hall during our
most intense battle I came gradually to
realize that partially demolishing the
Divinity School just might not measure
up to Vince's standard of preserving
heaven on earth I surrendered these
skirmishes and other less charged
conversations with Vince were the
beginning of my education and
architecture and urban planning I was a
novice and Vince was one of those who
helped me learn to honor the built
environment of Yale and New Haven Vince
Vince smiled upon much of the work of
our later years the construction of
venturi San lien Center and especially
the meticulous and faithful restorations
of the Davies mansion and three
modernist classics Kahn's gallery the
rudolph building an eagle's ring vince
believed that Yale's buildings are its
greatest treasures but anyone as
privileged as I was to meet thousands of
students and alumni knows that Yale's
teachers are its greatest treasures even
more powerfully than the buildings
Yale's teachers shape lives and give
their students that
fools to make sense of the world Vince
gave thousands of VF graduates a gift of
immense value immeasurable value the
capacity to see to feel the power of
what they see and to think critically
about what they see and feel beneath all
the fire and brimstone of this supremely
articulate critic was a deep humanity
Vince cared he cared about Yale
his students and the football team he
cared about buildings and streets and
parks and not for themselves alone but
for the impact they had on people and
communities his brilliance passion and
his caring touched us and inspired us
his City his University and most of all
his students
ignoring the vituperative outbursts of
ideologues of instance going made the
battle for the soul of modern
architecture seem like a conversation
among reasonable people an historian a
critic and a passionate public
intellectual through his writings
Vincent Scully will continue to be
central to architectural thinking for
generations to come
I was privileged to study under Vince
more than fifty years ago his wisdom and
friendship had benefited me over the
many years since ending with my times
dean when he was sterling professor
emeritus of the history of art of art in
architecture as a teacher as we know and
I've already heard Vince inspired
virtually thousands of students Yale
undergraduates who would take away from
his classes a sense that they too had a
responsibility to help shape the
physical world and the roster of
architectural professionals who were
Scully students constitutes a veritable
who's who of contemporary practice
extending from those of my generation to
a younger generation now reaching
maturity and even those who are just
making their voices heard it is for this
reason as much as for his scholarship
his critical writing and his brilliant
insights that Philip Johnson proclaimed
him the most influential architecture
teacher ever
Scully's path-breaking first book the
shingle style 1955 not only put an
enduring name to a hitherto undefined
American tradition it also provided us
with a definitive understanding of an
appreciation for the formal and cultural
differences between European and
American architecture spawning work by
former students of my generation that he
described
with pride and not a little irony as the
historians revenged though fiercely
committed to the discipline of art
history vince was an active participant
in the life of the architecture school
it was Vince who helped sort out the
myths that lay in the wake of George
house retirement in 1954 and it was
Vince who argued on behalf of Paul
Rudolph who he believed could best
return the program to glory in my
student days students came to Yale
because of rudolph and because of Scully
in the late 1960s when architecture
students began to protest against what
they characterized correctly in my
opinion as the overblown heroics of
American modernists and especially their
participation in the destructive
slash-and-burn urban renewal strategies
that were then coming to the fore Scully
one of the few faculty who commanded
student respect amidst the protests
embraced their cause drawing on his deep
scholarship to help shape their argument
but never abandoning his essential
belief that protests carried with it
responsibility for decorum in 1990 when
the university still held to a mandatory
retirement age of 70
Vince was forced to give up teaching he
was furious as you can imagine I mean
unless did my help and no doubt many
others of you in this room to make his
case to the president of the university
for continuing on but it was Thomas
Beebe the Dean of the school who saved
the day by offering a teaching position
in the graduate program which came with
a much reduced salary but that wasn't
the point for Vince he was overjoyed to
remain in the classroom by the time I
became Dean in 1998 Vince was more than
ever a principal citizen of Yale
a force measure to be respected and as
president Levin has already alluded to
on at least one notable occasion feared
one of the few who dared to speak out
about architectural issues on Yale's
campus issues of stewardship and respect
for the past when in spring 1999 with
President Levin's support I convened a
symposium to assess the university's
programs for renovation and new
construction one topic came to the fore
the decision to demolish four buildings
at the Delano and Aldrich designed
Divinity School campus Scully was the
keynote speaker but after reviewing the
plans during the course of the event
that had been presented for remodeling
the Divinity School he asked that he be
allowed to return to the platform at the
end of the of the three-day gathering at
which time before a packed audience
including numerous architects who had
been his students looking directly at
president Levin he said quote if the
Divinity School were rebuilt according
to the present plan I'd have to rethink
my future in this institution loyalty
can only be stretched can be stretched
only so far needless to say the
building's threatened with the wrecking
ball were saved but even more
importantly Vince helped spark a man
you'd respect as president xi has made
clear for the role architecture can and
does play in a great university my own
personal debt to Vincent Scully as that
is countless of student countless
students is immense because of Vincent
Scully generations of architects and
others have chosen to pursue an
architecture and urbanism rooted in
memory rather than amnesia
with a scholars knowledge and an actor's
passion Vincent Scully helped us to
appreciate the empathetic relationship
between human
and it's masterworks of the built
environment perhaps his greatest
contribution of all was that he taught
us how to save
well I got up here
and I really you know why I'm here
because Vince didn't like me at least to
the beginning and it because I breezed
into New Haven in I remember what you
just when he had established a kind of
master plan for the downtown area and I
arrived at the Knights of Columbus and
plopped it in there and a couple of
other things and for several reasons he
didn't like the Knights of Columbus
family but he we sort of stayed away
from each other for a long time and then
he we moved to the jungle on the
Waterloo just on the bay and we would go
out there every summer with our children
and there was this man who rode past
every Sunday and it turned out to be
Venice and he was drawing a very
expensive and professional boat but
Lovgren alors and after a few years we
started to wave to each other and then
he would occasionally come and play with
the children which is very nice his
right firstly so we got to be good
friends but our start was uneven because
I really didn't have any sense of
just to explain how I got him in the
first place
I was at school in Dublin during the war
Ireland was not involved in the war so I
graduated just as them all finished and
I felt I had to get out from those O'War
and I went to London to maximum fine
changeover wood then the leading
architects and and if you went back and
decided I would come to America question
is where now when I was at Metro fires I
saw a magazine which was loading and
then he thought of all very much and I
said when I come study with it and so I
when I got back to Nome I applied to
Yale Harvard and IIT release was and
incredibly I was accepted at all three
and I can't imagine why because I didn't
have those they have to show but I
decided to go with Mies and just brief
story there for about four months he
never talked to us and then that we got
a little problem to design a house a
little bit Lincoln Chicago of the
stove's about six feet deep and
everybody decide that fourth houses but
I thought well you know in Scandinavia
they wouldn't do that why didn't I catch
you to pitch to us and so we slip
briefly and they said you could do that
but I would not do that you know
I decided it was time to move on and I
did and then joined eros darling had
that wonderful ten years I saw that when
I came here I was kind all of the arrows
but it was he died before he had planned
to move from did fight of our world to
here and I ended up with
responsibilities to complete six of his
buildings and I thought all of that he
read pleased into New Haven with all
these ideas and I sat beside a man on
the plane coming here and very nice but
turned out he was the mayor and when I
got off the plane I had the Knights of
Columbus building and a new school in my
part so I thought gee this is a nice
place but then I ran thought into the
Vince
he couldn't understand
and we didn't speak to each other or
inadvertently about each other for a
couple of years and then we I don't know
if I mentioned this but we got it got a
cherry would roll past the what was
sometimes read the children so we got to
be good friends and he was a very
charming very articulate very wonderful
person and I agreed to do this even
though he would have preferred them
should just come back and sit down
the innumerable things that vin scully
taught us i only have time to focus on
three first and foremost he taught us in
art history that none of us had heard
before his passionate searing lectures
glowed with familiar names to be sure
Giotto Michelangelo Palladio but also
Picasso Pollock Louis Kahn and Maya Lin
but he also focused of course on
well-known historical figures like
jefferson and louis xiv and his military
engineer Vauban vince had a historical
imagination and left us with a palpable
sense of history of the ages russian by
and new vistas coming to the fore but
for Vince the past was never really past
it was always intersecting with the
presence in the moving lecture he showed
how some of the boss 17th century forts
were flooded by the French during World
War two
in order to slow down the advance of
Hitler's troops and I remembered the
sense of bitter disappointment when the
lights went on in the law school
auditorium and we had to balloon down to
Planet Earth and readjust to our
everyday existence we wanted to stay on
on Vincent Vincent Scully's magic carpet
in the company of these great men and
women Brunelleschi Titian George
Washington heroic figures like this
himself larger-than-life generous
lion-hearted and this epic yardstick
which he used in his lectures was the
only one of course by which we could use
to but the only one by which we could
judge and Scully himself it is not by
chance I think that so many of his
lectures touched on the subject of war
he wrote memorably about Michelangelo's
fortification drawings for Florence or
those of Obama or of Edwin Lutyens great
memorial to the
thus dead soldiers who died at the
Battle of the Somme in World War one its
Eva there were still battles to be
fought battles that we had to fight and
Vince wanted he fought for in art
history that came down from the sacred
groves of academia and he was deeply
deeply concerned involved engaged in the
contemporary world as an art historian
in 1989 when the Corcoran Gallery of Art
bowed to pressure and canceled an
exhibition of the work of robert
mapplethorpe Vince gave a stirring
lecture about freedom of expression
reminding us that we had to stand up
again and again he brought up civil
rights in lecture and as a president
Levin and several Bob Sturm also pointed
out went his beloved Yale threatened to
tear down a building
Vince thundered at his alma mater and
the words he used in lecture to US
students was that Yale acted like a
quote mean little Yankee institution
art history had to be militant and
proactive it had to intervene in the
world around it
second thing has already run up a Bob
Stern [ __ ] taught us how to see but the
way he taught us he taught us how to see
sorry Vince taught us how to teach the
way he treated us the way he correct us
with humor so it was not so that we
would not be humiliated the way he
vented all our talks before we became
ridiculous at symposia he always Vettes
he gave us time these were all
invaluable lectures for the future and
there was also his and Happy's warm
hospitality in their home and in every
one of those dinners every time happy
would begin a story in pause in
mid-sentence and Vince would finish the
phrase for it wasn't too many years
later when I myself was married that I
was aware of how unusual that was a
husband and wife with the same version
of the same event you were a partnership
working closely with one another and
that too is a lesson that stayed with us
finally and here I come - Bob Stearns
point Vince taught us how to see but for
Vince seeing was not something passive
it wasn't something that just happened
it required work commitment risk and
always imagination all of us who studied
with Vince have taken detours of a
hundred miles or more to see something
he had mentioned in lecture and how many
of us grad students would find ourselves
one day in the
back country road in Italy under a
torrential downpour waiting for a bus
that might come in an hour or two or a
day or two you look down your clothes or
new leather shoes were ruined mud falls
boozing out but you didn't care we had
just seen a Pilate in Villa that Vince
had mentioned and we knew that our life
was enriched amplified by this
experience but Vince could never teach
us to see the way that he did because he
had an exceptional ability to compare
things that were separated by thousands
of years for example or thousands of
miles and when he made these startling
connections he was always right and a
striking example of this as already
being brought up by Professor Levin was
this precisely the peril that he brought
up between the urban plan of New Haven
an exec Ian of the ideal City nine
perfect squares with twelve gates and a
temple in the center facing the sea but
Vince was not it was not about pure
formal analogy it was always something
more he was always after the bigger
picture and he adds quote it is touching
that the city Zico described is intended
as a refuge for the people who left
Jerusalem after Jerusalem was taken and
destroyed as he wrote in Yale and New
Haven architecture and urbanism the book
he co-authored with Tapie Paul
Goldberger
and Eric vote New Haven is Ezekiel's
vision to the life the nine square city
by the sea the red mountain flaring it
is the New Jerusalem the most perfect of
all the Puritan towns and we shall now
hear the Society of orcas and Bacchus
seeing a version of Jerusalem that was
rewritten in order to reflect business
collie vision of
native city as the New Jerusalem
[Music]
I see
ooh
[Music]
[Music]
bring me my chariot of
[Music]
[Applause]
my two
my screen
[Music]
[Music]
president salivate tapi members of the
Skelly family please know it is for me a
very great honor to take part in this
memorial tribute a student is here to be
taught to see and to believe that
anything is possible he told me in an
interview for a piece I was writing
about him for the old architectural
forum in 1959 he was 39
I was 26 on another occasion only about
10 years ago we had met one evening for
a drink at the Yale Club in New York and
as we stepped out of the elevator of the
second floor and walked into the main
lounge he stopped to look up at at the
spectacular ceiling of that room and
exclaimed very softly almost as if he
were talking to himself
god I loved Yale he had only just gotten
off the train from New Haven but then of
course the Yale Club is another of the
master works outstanding works of James
cable gamble Rodgers the genius who
created Harkness Tower and so much else
all around us here less than a year ago
in the course of a conversation I asked
Vince who was your favorite teacher who
had the most influence on you he said
she was his New Haven high school
English teacher senior year miss
Sheridan
he said she rep made me read the New
York Times every Sunday and especially
the book review
it was then I came to realize as I never
had until then how much there was to
read and I began reading books books of
all kinds as never before already by the
1950s when I was an undergraduate his
talks filled the whole lecture hall the
old lecture hall in the art gallery
every seat was taken and many who were
unregistered for the course was stand
along the side walls or sit on the
stairs leading up to the balcony he
would enter moving fast and go
immediately up to thon stage make a few
quick remarks about schedules or
something of that kind in a rather
nondescript quick voice then the hall
would turn dark very dark a large image
would fill a giant screen behind him and
the show was underway the voice now
strong urban slightly theatrical would
unleash what one friend of his called a
musical avalanche a picture making words
never relying on a written script or
notes and stopping only only to bring
out the heavy ten-foot long pointer on
this banging on the stage floor to
signal a change in the image on the
screen there's one story that he was got
so excited one day he fell off the stage
onto the floor and kept right on with
his lecture I certainly do believe it
often to make a point about a particular
painting or a work of architecture he
would throw in an unexpected quote from
James Joyce or scott Fitzgerald or
pilgrims progress or The Odyssey you
name it and often with marked effect
though there were times
when the connection seems a bit of a
stretch many of the most of his most
impassioned lectures would be long
remembered and have far-reaching effect
for me it was those talks he delivered
on the great cathedrals of France
nasally in particular and Jefferson's
campus at the University of Virginia and
yes on the Brooklyn Bridge but most of
us who were students here in the in in
my time it was important also that he
has served in World War two as an
officer in the Marine Corps in both
Europe and the Pacific
nor did it matter that he and the other
veterans on the faculty of the time
seldom ever talked about the war if at
all they didn't have to one beautiful
spring evening back then one or two of
other two other students and I were
coming out of the torch Honors Society
with Vince when suddenly he stopped and
looked up at the sterling Tower just
down College Street glowing in late
golden sunshine look at that he said
architects don't build just with steel
and stone they build with light he
helped us to see as no one ever had
helped us also importantly to understand
that history is far more than just
politics and war he showed us what he
loved again and again and with genuine
infectious enthusiasm we could never say
enough in tribute or any gratitude to
our great teachers in so many measurable
ways they are the most important and
admirable men and women of all
we can never give them enough credit or
expand or Express sufficient
appreciation above all they have
generation generation after generation
shaped
our values our sense of purpose our
desire desire to excel in whether is we
chose to make of our lives and how
wonderful that for all the time Vincent
Scully spent in Greece in New Mexico and
elsewhere all the ground he covered
geographically and in his mind there was
no place he's so loved as New Haven
Connecticut his home ground what an
uplifting life story he remains the
scholarship boy who became a national
treasure gone but not forgotten is the
old expression it's my view that if not
forgotten they're not gone on we go
you all know what this is I asked it to
be put up here on the stage as a as a
kind of an homage to Vincent in an
effort to count garner your attention
during my short talk thank God no one
turned out the lights
we all knew Vincent in different ways in
my case he was a mentor and an
inspiration over the course of a
lifetime whether as his student
occasionally looking at slides in the
slide room in preparation for his next
lecture in my career as an art dealer or
as the owner of the Miami Marlin
baseball team i implemented lessons he
taught me every day of my life I
wouldn't be where I am in my life
without him in the late 1950s oh that's
so long ago I started taking classes at
Yale in the art history department and
it became my major mostly because of the
indelible impression Vincent made upon
me like he has done for hundreds and
maybe thousands of others he was more
than an art and architectural giant he
was magnetic part brilliance part
showmanship when he spoke you listened
the things he taught me I couldn't have
learned anywhere else he was about
energy truth high standards wisdom
inspiration poetry and certainly made
architecture come to life
I've been around many of the world's
greatest painters and sculptors and
being in Vincent's company
was no different in my life
visuals and interpretation are always
critical and it was Vincent who taught
me how to use my eyes to see not only
the given and the obvious how do you
measure works of art and architecture
against one another and against your own
knowledge are they good
are they great are they successful it's
all about using your eyes
I wondered then and probably still
wonder now how the hell he could see the
things he saw his eyes missed nothing in
his humanistic approach to architecture
buildings were living entities not just
slabs of concrete populating the horizon
and he taught me that we live the way we
do because of the things that surround
us we take too much for granted he often
said to me and are comfortable with the
status quo well and soon often always
said that you don't have to accept being
crippled by visual pollution I never
forgot that I remember Vincent calling
me one day to elicit my help apparently
and you've heard this before there was a
discussion about removing some of the
buildings at the Divinity School which
he felt was a crime those were his words
he felt that it still had more years to
live and had an important place on
campus he asked me to call president
Levin and lobby for his cause
the buildings were saved certainly not
because of me but rather because of his
Herculean efforts to pull out all the
stops for something he believed in
when my daughter arrived at Yale many
years after me I suggest that you take
his course since he was nearing the end
of his career
sure enough the year after she took that
course he retired we come back as a
visiting professor and teach classes
once in a while smacking that loud
corner on the floor to capture the
audience's attention have the lights go
out and the magic begin
I ordered it one of his classes many
years ago along with my wife Julie and
noticed that everything was the same
except instead of feverishly scribbling
notes on paper paper students were now
feverishly typing away on their laptops
it's beautiful that he had such a
profound influence on so many
generations Vincent was such a towering
presence on campus that even his little
French Citroen automobile which he
usually parked on Park Street behind
Pearson College was always very visible
I recall one day walking down the street
with a group of friends and football
players and we all spotted the car one
suggested that we pick it up carry it
across the street and put it on the
steps of st. Thomas More church the
following Monday at his art and
architecture class Vincent came in
slammed his pointer to the ground looked
at everyone in the seat in their seats
and said who were the wise guys who put
my car on the steps of the church
there were no responses at the Yale
football
Yale Harvard football game seven or
eight or nine years ago I mentioned to
Julie that I was going to tell Vincent
about that incident enough years had
passed and I thought he should know they
turned around and described it to him
and took full responsibility he gave me
a hug and said that was so marvelous he
he carried no grudges he had a great
sense of humor last time I saw Vincent
was in Miami when he and Tapie were
living there
I always invited them to come to the
ballpark on opening day which was always
very festive and a wonderful experience
he loved the combination and the
commotion and the camaraderie with the
players and the uplifting atmosphere and
he would always call me afterwards to
say thank you profusely and comment on
the energy I don't know what the energy
he was looking at but there were lots of
cheerleaders I knew that all was well in
his eyes
and his heart recently I began to think
a lot about him and tremendous emotions
came roaring back in my mind I wanted to
call him and see him again exactly 12
after hours after I had that thought I
heard that he had passed away timing is
everything
blowing obituaries came roaring in from
the New York Times The Washington Post
Associated Press and others barely
capturing the positive impact he had on
generations of architects and most
importantly young aspiring curious minds
many of them here at Yale many of those
who took his introductory course
never went on to study art history but
the exposure of two Vincent's world
I'm sure made them even more curious
about their environments
I love demand the early now we are left
with the memory and his writings and an
indelible image of a genius and we have
opportunity here now to honor his legacy
by inspiring the next generation to
ensure that his magical spirit continues
thank you
Vince's simply the most inspiring and
influential teacher I had as an
undergraduate like so many students I
was enthralled by how events would take
us from the Acropolis to Monticello and
to the pueblos of New Mexico all in an
hour leaving us an absolute awe of the
power beauty and import of these great
works when I returned to jail
architecture school I was his head TA
for my years back at Yale I would often
stay with him in the art history slide
room and watch as he would put that
day's lecture together with his
incredible concentration as he composed
the day's talk each lecture totally
afresh with hundreds of images to be
projected side-by-side all laid out on
the light tables in the art history
slide it was a rare opportunity to see a
master at work and to begin to
understand how his ability to thread
that day's lecture together was a
brilliant composition that visually
flowed and connected as well as being
thematically and conceptually linked
this visual composition created an
almost film light sequence and allowed
you to easily sit through hundreds upon
hundreds of images in that darkened
auditorium like individual film stills
all pieced together
connected with his moving booming
passionate voice and this sequencing
made it so easy for him to quite
literally transport you from the pueblos
of New Mexico to the stone monumental
structures of Mesoamerica to the Grand
Canyon and then on to the canyons of New
York City these talks would literally at
times take your breath away and leave
you in awe of the power of architecture
actually in the power of the human
spirit that would create they could
create those works for Vince inspired us
to think about the humanity within
architecture and how the built
environment influences who we are both
as an individual and as a society his
was a belief that architecture can
elevate the spirit and can inspire us to
help shape our world for the better
I for one ovince such a great death it
was in my senior year my very last
seminar where Vince described a world
war one memorial to the missing in Kiev
all France for the Battle of the Sun
that Sir Edwin Lutyens had designed he
described it as a psychological journey
to Inverness about loss and that you had
to walk through a gaping scream of an
archway inscribed with the over 70,000
names of the missing from the Battle of
the Somme and as he so powerfully and
eloquently described the experience of
that memorial I realized that a certain
project of mine that I had designed for
a fall class project for it was a
memorial to the Vietnam War
had a similar psychological experience
it was a journey to an awareness about
loss although the two designs could not
have been more different formally while
still in that class I started madly
writing Vince was more than a little
curious but that written description of
the design was the final part that I've
been struggling with before I could send
the competition boards in and Vince's
description of the legends Memorial was
instrumental in making me understand
that my design
worked on a similar psychological level
he made you feel architecture was a
living and breathing presence for those
of us fortunate to have pursued the arts
and architecture his was a voice that
impressed upon us the deep
responsibilities we each would have in
making our own works and for so many
others he inspired a sense of wonder
respect and wants responsibility for the
built environment he gave you a deeper
understanding of how much our built
works
express our very humanity and how much
through these works we can and should
influence and shape society
Vince urged us to think of the great
social responsibility its responsibility
these works could have in his own voice
in his introduction to American
architecture and urbanism he writes
there is no difference between
architecture and city planning all must
now or rather again be treated as one
this must be especially so because of
the fact that every citizen must now
share an active and critical
responsibility for the future of the
America
city as for that of the American
community as a whole his vote and his
direct personal intervention and his own
community can help determine the kind of
world we will make he made us want to
help shape a better world and the world
of the sorely missing
good afternoon it's an honor to be with
you
I speak representing my partner under
testimony who's here and many friends in
Miami where Vincent happy had a home for
some 20 years Vincent Scully represents
an era a time and modern architecture
that influenced by his teaching and
writing sought reconnection with
historic glories confronting a building
in the classroom with drama and urgency
as Michael Lewis put it one of many
recent articles about vents confronting
a building in the classroom had the
effect of making all architecture
contemporary Vince taught us to value
all that was good in architecture as
chewing an ideology a gift allowing us
to appreciate the world around us with
freedom unfettered by ideology for which
we are grateful and the conviction that
past and present are one has guided
generations of his students it's
important to review the spelling era in
the future it may be seen very
differently differently than our
experience of it already sometimes it is
misrepresented as cosmetic fantasy he
might exhort us of all to make a record
of this time from our own experiences to
keep this record straight that others
may not skew the perspective for many
here today it is not an exaggeration to
say if not for Vince we would not be
doing what we do as students we
understood his historical benchmarks and
imagined our own work having a life
between the achievements of our
predecessors and a future that would
support continuity and we assimilated
his principles of civic responsibility
and
preservation and urban engagements
Scully's own such engagements ricochet
still today and still remembered
critiques of development in Miami I'm
still hearing about them and the renewed
impetus for the revival of New York's
Pennsylvania Station which is also still
an ongoing discussion many have said
that Professor Skelly changed the course
of American architecture indeed the
breadth of his audience and his
influence on the built environment
brought wide recognition much of it from
beyond his home in academia even from
the real estate development industry
consider his award from the Urban Land
Institute in 2003 the JC Nichols prize
for visionaries in urban development
what other academic can claim honors
from such a quarter from this and I the
Scully era had two phases the first as
students and young architects trying to
imagine that we were part of the
historical continuum we still remember
vividly the intellectual Awakening and
excitement of the Scully lectures from
those emerged our interest in the whole
of American architecture not just in
public buildings and monuments but in
the American house in the American
community this was the foundation for
the movement called the new urbanism and
the assessment that it was time to
recover the beauty and good sense of
American settlements it also encouraged
the traditional and classical
architecture revival that thrives across
the world today the second phase began
when Vincent tapi joined us as
colleagues at the University of Miami
they were a team he taught his favorite
courses and she taught American
architecture and preservation they came
to love the Florida vernacular including
the modest indignant
early ranch houses one of which they
chose to inhabit Vince loved our
affinity with the Caribbean and he
encouraged us to emphasize the distinct
that distinction
Vincent tapi truly adopted our school
giving impetus to the faculty and
students to seek a regional identity the
success in doing so is chronicled by
them in the book between two towers and
is evident in numerous ensuing faculty
publications and buildings we remember
with happiness those special years in
Miami we are grateful to have known
Vince's creative intellect generosity
and mentoring principled passion a
mischievous sense of humor and above all
his loyal friendship and dearest happy
we look forward to your return to Miami
hi we're shades of Yale none of us knew
professor Scully personally but we've
been told that he loved undergraduates
that he loved teaching them and learning
with them and he always set up vehement
ly for what he believed in and so we're
so honored to be here and to help pay
tribute to his memory this is we shall
overcome
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes someday hey sisters and rather be
shy
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I just have to do this first you know
who's here
Helen chill Minh at 91 years old the
slide librarian who made everything and
I think it's right to clap for her and
for all the projectionists and all the
slide runners and all the TFS and if
you're at home watching this you can
stand up and we'll applaud you now
[Applause]
so here is the C checkerboard films is
making a film on Vince and as the master
of je and a special assistant to the
president I have been asked to go with
my dear friends Vincent a P and the
video makers and show the way to various
Al buildings and opened gates with my
swipe card now it is the middle of the
day and with the video team we are at
the Yale Bowl it is this December and
the place resembles Vostok Antarctica
icicles sticking to the hard seats where
we are sitting a Tundra of grass before
us nothing like the bowl on a gorgeous
autumn day I am sitting there waiting
for Vince to say something wonderful
about this Yale place which he has known
since his childhood in which he loves so
well when suddenly he turns to tapi and
me the cameras are rolling the audio is
on and says you know Harvard Stadium is
a better place to watch a football game
shock and horror I gamely smile and nod
for the cameras while my stomach Falls
25 stories on a crashing elevator what
the dreaded Harvard the school that has
caused us so much ecstasy when we beat
them in agony whenever in the gloom of a
gathering winter evening they ground us
into the dust of our field of dreams
truthfully I had often heard Vince say
that about Harvard Stadium Harvard
Stadium is great penny because you sit
on that brutal concrete it's war like
it's difficult life it's the Roman
Coliseum with the gladiators you sit
right up there on top of the action
where you can hear the cries of triumph
and anguish echo across the way but he
always said it in the context of our
perfect mutual understanding that of
course nothing nothing nothing matched
the expanse
magnificence of the bowl inspiration for
the Rose Bowl the Michigan Stadium the
Los Angeles Memorial Coliseum nothing
matched that on a gorgeous fall day and
frankly I didn't think he ever would
praise anything about the dreaded
Harvard on a film about himself and Yale
so this little episode made me think
about Richard Conniff swards about Vince
that he was the perfect inside-outside
man but actually while that phrase has a
rightness about it the truth is that
Vince was not an inside man or an
outside man or an inside outside man and
that is because he wasn't anybody's man
at all
maybe tapis but nobody else's and he was
determinable irrefutable unstoppably and
unceasingly his own person and in the
black pit that covers us from pole to
pole he was the captain of his ship he
was the master of his soul
I met Vince in the 1970s when I was
teaching in yells English department and
Vince reached out to my late husband the
poet and translator Robert Fitzgerald
because he loved Homer and admired
Roberts translations and we became
friends but I really came to know Vince
and Tapie in the latest 1980s when we
began going to football together
I discovered that Vincent tap he has
Vince had done most of his life they
were sitting in the cheap seats far from
the action as he else somewhat
improbable faculty athletic
representative I had four amazing seats
in portals 16 right behind the president
and I offered two of these to Vincent
tapi Vince theatrically snored and and
twitted me mercilessly the very idea
that he the son of a New Haven aldermen
the fiery defender of Yale radicals in
the occasional gadfly troublemaker to
Yale presidents who me nevertheless
loved and always underlined protected
him the very idea of sitting up there
with the establishment horrified him
but allow me to convey that despite
those frightful reservations
he took the Seas and so for over a
quarter century he and Tapie and I
through Sun and rain through hidden snow
year in and year out through ecstatic
winds and catastrophic losses sat in
them together even early on I always
knew that going to football as we did
was not only about the football though
it was about that football games
connected Vince to his New Haven
childhood when he told me he and his
father would walk or ride out on the
trolley to the bowl and his father would
lift him up and sometimes even put him
on his shoulders so he could see the
fury of the game above the crowd it was
about driving through the New Haven
streets to get to the bowl because he
knew every street and every one of okhta
memory it was about parking on the side
of Edgewood Park and walking through
autumn leaves past the duck pond and
then up Chapel Street entering the
complex and going through the dark
tunnel and coming out out out into the
sky with the blue Yale flag flying
before us on the other side it was about
viewing the field as a palimpsest on
which he could see Alby blue whom he had
actually seen play and all the other
players he had known in all the other
ages moving in the shadows behind the
current players on the field it was
about that bellicose competitive thing
in him that wanted to triumph and found
its match in the game it was about the
neighborhood of these things it was
about the ritual of them the bowl in
football were to Vince of synthesis of
everything about his childhood an age of
Yale and New Haven and of the way all
this could come together on his Saturday
afternoon although there was something
in Vince's vitality that fought the wave
of death until it literally overwhelmed
him there was also something of his
knowledge of death in his devotion to
the necessary excellence of the
buildings that will survive as monuments
to what we cherish he had such a
perfectly tuned acute awareness of death
which is his Wallace Stephen said the
mother of beauty a few months before my
late husband's death years ago I sent a
New Year's poem that seemed to be about
a football game that Yale had won with a
fantastic Hail Mary pass at the end the
last lines were then throw the ball out
man just throw the ball longer than
you've ever thrown before and wake and
when with every banner waving your name
announced in every trumpet call your
crowd and teammates
ferry you ashore Vince was the only one
the man with the power of vision and
acute sensitivity to language the man
with the perfect awareness of the
imperishable beauty human should strive
for who saw what my verse was about his
was the tragic sense joyful about life
despite facing the inevitability of
oblivion in which great buildings are a
stay against what he termed nature
implacable human will unbreakable he
came up to me and said that poems not
about football penny is it that's about
Robert dying the triumphalist of the
spirit as he is being ferried ashore out
of the arena in the arms of those he
loves Vince saw that and that is what
with Tapie we are doing here we are all
of us his family and friends
collectively varying Vince ashore in a
place where his end is in his beginning
at home in New Haven and at Yale
hello I'm Stephen the second of the
skully's in your program I thought I
would recall a moment from our childhood
the date is 1957 we are living in Greece
for the year and at this moment we are
at marathon I'm 10 the middle of three
boys all five of us my mother and father
my brothers and I are packed in a der
cheveux the very car that mr. Laura is
just mentioned it's a tin can of a
vehicle front and back seats
I made a rubber band covered in cloth
it's got a canvas roof which can roll
down from front to back we all love this
thing it's little more than a circus car
as you've already heard as its name
implies it has two cylinders and
struggles against the wind in groans
going uphill at the moment at marathon
were on the flat just under the shoulder
of the mountain with the road such as it
is running straight to the sea a mile
away eight states according to herodotus
where the mighty Persian army has
disembarked from its ships dad puts the
car in full throttle and we race across
the plane as fast as the car can go just
as the Athenians in full battle gear
broke into a run racing to clash with
the Persians who had landed on their
Shores dad start shouting Dallas Dallas
the sea the sea and we join in roaring
as loud as our lungs can it's an
exhilarating experience 60 years ago now
also more than two thousand years ago
we are the ancient Athenians we're
Americans in Greece I can still feel the
rush of it the battle for freedom
thallus is a great word to shout did
this moment that this year turned me
into a classicist probably in some way
but I couldn't say just how other things
about my father much more obviously did
my fascination my fascination with the
Greek gods dad's love my love for Greek
polytheism his persistent passion in
questioning what makes for community how
does a community conceal itself how does
it share in the divine if at all what
gives it shape cohesion how do buildings
how do individuals fit together or not
and making something greater than the
part these are things abstractly
speaking I teach that I write about I
think of them as Greek questions coming
from Greek authors like Homer he ca
Aeschylus Sophocles Euripides and Plato
but I also know deep down that they come
from you dad that they are inspired by
your own questions this is a bond that
keeps us close in some sense and in some
sense makes scholarship autobiographical
and that is probably a good thing too
this is the Greek moment I wish to share
here with you today and indulge me as I
end my remarks with words I spoke at
dads burial as the obituaries testified
many who hardly knew our father loved
him
and what they loved about him was that
he enabled them to see what they had
only dimly imagined before and he gave
them soaring words to help them see what
they now saw what I want to say here is
that I loved him for the same reasons
although I would phrase them a little
differently dad taught me to look and
look and look until I finally saw he
gave me the drive to look until I could
see he also gave me the confidence to
trust what I had seen and he gave me the
confidence to trust my imagination in
extending what I saw into an expressive
narrative these are the gifts of a great
teacher and of a great parent
for most of us 64 years of teaching at
Yale dad's office wasn't on the arch
bridge over High Street with with in
with windows looking toward sterling
library downstairs was the slide room
first and what is now the art gallery
and and in pregnant Street Hall his
slides were always close by always
watched over by Helen Tillman twice a
week to have to walk those slides up
High Street pass Harkness tower and keep
moving toward the beloved Egyptian great
gate at the Grove Street Cemetery but
always stopped at the law school
auditorium to perform his magic with
those slides and send so many forth to
see the world anew fact is it's hard to
talk about that without his side-by-side
slides picture this on the left a High
Street bridge connecting the art gallery
with Street Hall and on the other side
at the other end of High Street the
Egyptian gate to the Grove Street
Cemetery
together these bookend the space of High
Street you could call this dad space in
December we buried dad in the grove
street cemetery now he is has completed
the full length of High Street from the
bridge district to the Egyptian gate
appropriately he is now essentially on
axis with the Law School Auditorium
across the street
and within the shadows of where his high
school once stood which is Morrison
styles now he isn't a perfect place
during World War two while on a ship off
the Sicilian coast dad saw his first
vision of a Greek temple ruins rising
above the ocean a vision that he never
felt that he carried him all through his
life on a cemetery stone will be a
drawing by by his son John our brother
of a temple ruin posed above the earth
and between the Earth and sky above the
ocean thank you all for Dad besides
being dad you established the thematic
axis and focus of my work much love but
how does one think tappy tappy has made
to have so much to do with his attaining
the life well-lived 297 and in the style
which he did
Yale has been the very center of Vince's
life since that first football game with
his father 93 years ago it would have
touched fence beyond telling that Yale
would memorialize him in the splendid
way it has done today that these friends
and family would have spoken so fondly
of him and that all of you would have
braved the call to be here especially my
friends from Virginia
I am emboldened now to say anything at
all because I love fence and promised
him that I would speak if any memorial
service was held for it if indeed and
because I do want to assure you that
although he has been in exile from his
beloved New Haven for the last six years
and oh how heinous this place and to
show you that although Parkinson's took
at all fenced in enjoy life bravely
until the very few weeks before his
death Vince decided to leave our dear
little house in New Haven simply because
it couldn't climb the stairs to the only
bedrooms in the house and we had my
parents home in Lynchburg with a bedroom
on the ground floor his family and many
old friends hazard it the trick just
central Virginia he struck up near
friendships fair and one of his dearest
very dearest Lynchburg friends Don jowls
died only this morning he nurtured in
a new passion for the Opera
he played those disks had an
ear-splitting decibel level while he
pedaled away on his exercise bike for
the metaphor part of a daily hour until
just a month before he died
and he recognized Barrios that his
mother had sung so well she was a
semi-professional opera singer so many
decades before of course Vince read
incessantly he wrote everything he wrote
a little he agonized over the present
peril in which the country finds itself
we streamed movies nightly he missed
growing so much that he took his robots
to Lynchburg just so he could look at
them
he missed teaching so much that he made
new pupils of his lung young therapist
he gave them classic novels can discuss
the books while they exercise together
no one has mourned Vince's death more
than our husky Enzo who would not leave
from his bedside until then Vince did
not talk much about about death except
to say how much he hated to leave this
beautiful world but more than 30 years
ago in a film he made for New York's
Metropolitan Museum he did talk about
death in relation to a painting in the
collection there before we all gather
again for a reception just across the
way a reception at the Art Gallery I
think it only fitting that we give the
last word in this service to Vincent's
himself in this clip from that film the
title is from a poem by William Cullen
Bryant very strange poem for a young man
to write in which attempts to reconcile
mankind to dying by pointing out that
the majority of mankind lies dead in the
earth and that fun one dies one goes
back as it were home to nature and
becomes part of it and the painting is
like that under the trees as a quiet
burial ceremony up to the right
magnificent alpine masses loom and
castles of great antiquity rest upon but
then down toward the light again is in
the Oxbow goes the lovely garden out to
the transcendence of the distance and so
on is made to feel that in dying in
being put to rest in the earth there is
a great peace and the earth itself
celebrates the grandeur of the coming
and out beyond in the distance
the light of transcendence flares all of
that speaks very close to American needs
seems to me at anytime for an American
who travels to Europe all of a sudden as
the realization that there is another
attitude toward death than ours one in
which it's more natural precisely
because the father's for so joining so
many generations sleep there and it's
this that attempt to reconcile Americans
to death to the common fate of all
mankind it's with that that thanatopsis
the poem and the painting deal to him
who in the love of nature holds
communion with her visible forms she
speaks of various language for his gayer
hours she has a voice of gladness and a
smile and eloquence of beauty and she
glides into his darker musings with a
mild and healing sympathy that steals
away their sharpness ere he is aware
when thoughts of the last bitter hour
come like a blight over thy spirit and
sad images of the stern agony and shroud
and all and breathless darkness in the
narrow house make thee to shudder and
grows sick at heart
go forth under the open sky and list two
nature's teachings so live that when thy
summons comes to join the innumerable
caravan which moves to that mysterious
realm where each shall take his chamber
in the silent halls of death thou go not
like the quarry slave at night scourge
to his dungeon but sustained and soon by
an unfaltering trust
approach thy grave like one who reps the
drapery of his couch about him and lies
down
- pleasant dreams that's what it's about
that's what Americans are trying to find
in the continent they're trying to find
that passed those father's graves they'd
like to belong here it's not possession
the furniture doesn't do you that much
good in that way the silver the great
chess a glossy clothes with the bright
buttons on them in the end you own
nothing you go back but you belong to
the land you returned to and there's
another kind of hope in transcendence
[Music]
[Music]